on the next episode of better call saul
i will put an end to this whatever it
takes
how did you leave things with howard
hamlin
we didn't miss anything thank you so
much doc of course come on in we'll take
a look
hey guys pete here d-day is upon us or
it will be by the end of the sixth
episode of better call saul's final
season today i'll be doing a preview of
what to expect based on the two
different teaser trailers the promo
photos which there is a big surprise in
those and everything else that's out
there to give us clues about this
upcoming episode there's some exciting
looking stuff here including a familiar
business card and a returning character
that we haven't seen for a couple of
seasons if any of that sounds like
spoilers to you then this is your chance
to leave and with that out of the way
let's get into it
the title of season six episode six is
axe and grind and the official summary
reads kim and jimmy enlist the
knowledgeable contact howard scrutinizes
jimmy's business practices the teaser
opens with some photos of jimmy howard
likely got these from his pi and that's
probably related to him looking into
those business practices and what i
presume is his home he says i will put
an end to this whatever it takes and the
whatever part of that feels ominous in
other howard news there is a shot of his
wife in the promo photos she's played by
sandrine holt which expands fans will
know as drummer's wife oxana or you
might recognize her from house of cards
the photo has her listed as cheryl
hamlin and we heard him mention her in
his therapy session back in episode 4.
it sounded like they were having
problems and you can imagine that
whatever he's going through as a result
of jimmy and kim's plans might be
stressing things further speaking of kim
we see her in a courtroom arguing a case
and noticed that cliff main is watching
you can't say for sure what's happening
here but this isn't the normal courtroom
that we usually see them in albuquerque
and that might be important but what
really jumps out here is a shot of an
isotopes air freshener this looks
exactly like the one we first saw in
jeff the cab driver's car in the gene
scene from season four her client is
definitely not jeff so it isn't clear if
this is related to his story directly it
could just be a nod to that scene or it
could be a pre-easter egg but i'm at a
loss on how this particular air
freshener would pop up again six or so
years later in omaha nebraska
outside the courtroom cliff asks how she
left things with howard hamlin so i'm
guessing he's there under the pretense
of seeing what she's doing with her pro
bono work but really he's trying to get
more information about what's happening
with howard that cuts to a shot of their
plan with kim standing in front in a way
that she's blocking some of the steps on
the left you see the ones we've already
seen unfold the country club the
kettlemans and wendy on the right you
can see a camera and eyeball t-minus one
and d-day she's crossing out the next to
the last one the one that reads t-minus
one which means they've made it to d-day
and that just has an illustration of a
mushroom cloud below it this appears to
mean that the plan to tarnish howard's
good standing will come to a conclusion
in the next episode which also happens
to be the mid-season finale in a recent
interview peter gould said that even
though they didn't know the season would
be split in two when they wrote it
episode 7 does end with a big
cliffhanger he said this is a big one i
think this is going to be a painful few
weeks for a few people to find out what
happens hopefully people will enjoy the
pain and not come after us with torches
this kind of sounds like we're not going
to see the aftermath of what the d-day
nuke looks like and later jimmy says we
didn't miss anything as they look at the
plan together and to me they look like
they're pretty pleased about how things
are playing out there's another shot
later where they're toasting with a
glass of wine he says here's to tomorrow
and she responds tomorrow and this is
where i start to wonder what's going to
come along to really screw things up it
looks like they have a good plan it
looks like they're pulling it off but
they look a little too relaxed with that
wine and howard is out there with a pi
and gus has his guys out there so there
may be a conflict there and there's
always the chance that lalo may come
back
before we get there we see everyone's
favorite shady veterinarian caldera the
last time we saw him was back in season
4 when he stitched nacho up before
telling him that the cartel stuff was
too hot and that he never wanted them to
contact him again here we see him
walking through his office he's putting
on some gloves and then there's a shot
of him shining a pen light in jimmy's
eyes as he sits on a table in the
voiceover you hear someone say thank you
so much doc and this doesn't sound like
jimmy at all and caldera responds of
course we'll take a look it's somewhat
confusing as to why jimmy would be
getting an exam from a veterinarian he
did have a black eye the last time we
saw him although it doesn't look like he
has it here and unless they're there for
something else already i don't see why
he would go to him for that you go see
this guy when you need something you
can't get anywhere else since they're
scheming it makes sense for them to
visit him for any number of reasons and
there was a promo photo from the first
batch that came out of jimmy and kim
looking at a notebook in his office in
that there's a dropper bottle by her
hand and that's likely why they're there
the post-it note board has an eye on it
there could be a connection there but
we're gonna have to wait and see what
that's all about what's really exciting
here is this quick shot of the notebook
that showed up in saul's house in the
episode one teaser it's the same one
from the promo photo and when they look
at it you can see the card for best
quality vacuum why is that important
because that's ed the disappearer shop
and there's been an ongoing mystery of
how jimmy knew about him from the first
episode we know jimmy has caldera's
notebook during the events of breaking
bad and at times in that series he
seemed to function in some of the same
ways as the vet so my working theory is
that caldera needs to use ed services to
disappear at the same time he's working
with these two and he leaves the
notebook behind with them because he
won't need it wherever he's going it's
coded but he may have given them the key
and him disappearing at this point would
explain how jimmy knows to trust ed and
why caldera isn't around in breaking bad
and then possibly how saul has so many
connections when he meets walt and jesse
we also get a look at jimmy's new office
which thanks to francesca's input is
much classier looking than it turns out
to be in the original series timeline
there's a shot of jimmy in his office
where we can see the film school kids
behind him it's always good to see those
guys and it looks like kim brings him a
bottle of zafiro to celebrate the
opening there's a shot of francesca
grimacing as one of his clients puts out
their cigarette on the armrest of the
new furniture and it looks like business
is still booming then there's a
conversation out back where jimmy tells
francesca to whom much is given much is
expected she looks reluctant but he
hands her his phone saying it's just a
phone call and that version of the
teaser ends as he makes a smiling face
at her you can see the toilet in the
trash can here and it really really
makes me wonder how they get from this
decor to the constitution mural behind
his desk i would guess that this is
related to the phone on the board from
the t-minus one part of the plan since
that's where we are if you look at the
other posts in that row one says seven
dash pc eight four two one five nine
that could be a case file or something
along those lines one says hhm and the
last one says delivery hal with a
question mark hard to say what that all
means but i expect this will be the
thing that sets howard over the edge
there are no gus sightings in either
teaser but there are a couple of shots
of mike there's one of him looking out a
window with binoculars that doesn't
provide much context for what might be
happening then there's a shot of him in
the laundry above the super lab and it's
cut to make it look like he might be
confronting lalo in a shot that's in a
dark place that possibly could be inside
the lab site he says i'm right here and
they cut that with a shot of lalo
holding a gun both of these are
somewhere dark but i don't think they're
in the same place it's not impossible
that he could show up in albuquerque
this week but it seems like there's
another step before he gets there and
there's a chance that we might see how
that plays out he has the slide rule
he'll track down who commissioned it
from the company that made it and when
we discussed this during the live stream
we thought it would be possible for them
to skip to his return but i'd still be
surprised if they did for what it's
worth it does seem like some time has
passed in between episodes or during the
episode itself considering so many steps
of the plan are complete and the office
work is already finished but i expect
more build up before the showdown with
mr salamanca there's also this last shot
of an axe and you can't really tell
what's going on in it but if i think of
who would be the scariest character to
be wielding it i go straight to lalo the
word axe is in the title so i was also
thinking that this might be from a
flashback maybe something in the teaser
but i haven't come up with any good
ideas about what this would be connected
to so we'll have to wait and see and
that's pretty much it for the trailers
as i mentioned at the beginning this is
pretty exciting looking seeing caldera
come back seeing the card for ed was a
big thrill getting an idea of how that
comes into the story since it plays such
an important part later and then seeing
howard's wife it all feels like we're
moving towards some big events here and
i really like how they illustrated that
by using d-day for the last step of the
plan and that mushroom cloud is a great
touch and i think that's a good place to
leave things please let me know in the
comments what you think about the
teasers in the upcoming episode how do
you think this is all gonna play out
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon